hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 so as my name is Caleb bendy and I
will be your driver on this journey
today the topic that I wanted to cover
is actually kind of a not a definite one
it's about some psychological factors in
chess it's about being afraid of your
opponent and that can show up in in many
many cases sometimes it can be a helpful
thing sometimes it can be a very very
unhelpful thing right it can change the
way that you play change change your
style of chess into something you're
less familiar with and that can
sometimes hurt your game and today we're
gonna be looking at it on the top level
so of course what player is everybody
else afraid of even at the the top
grandmaster level who is everybody
afraid of these days Magnus Carlsen of
course so we're gonna be like taking a
look at a couple of his games from the
world rapid championship and then
they're gonna be more examples of his
opponents being a little bit of afraid
of them not willing to play some lines
that that perhaps would have given them
a better chance then we're also gonna be
taking a look at a game of Peters
Fiddler's against Alireza firoozeh and
now freesia of course is a few you
fearless youngster he actually had a
pretty winning position against Magnus
Carlsen in this same tournament but
today we're gonna be looking at how he
stacked up against Peters Fiddler's and
maybe how he should have some fear of
these very talented chess players that
he's now coming up against
five minute games so these were actually
all rapid games so those were a bit
longer it was the world rapid and blitz
championship but we're gonna be taking a
look at the rapid the rapid portion
first though I wanted to do a quick
little warmup this is just a little
puzzle that I composed my friend Julian
Julian Pro ACO and just to get you guys
in in the chest mood let's see if you
guys are able to solve it it's actually
a checkmate puzzle for whites it's
checkmate in five so I'll let you guys
take a moment to calculate through get
the brain warmed up and we'll see how
you how you do here
as always we're keeping an eye on the
YouTube chat so if you guys have
anything interesting to say any ideas
for the games ideas for the puzzles
please just let me know and I'll read
your comments out loud hopefully
depending
so any first impressions on the puzzle
yes an IP v is should be one of your
candidate moves the important thing to
notice is that you don't really have
time to waste here
you can't play a slow move or something
I can't even think of a slow move but
you can't play a slow move because black
is threatening checkmate in like five
different ways and so you have to do
something to prevent all this and
usually that means the move is going to
be a check so Knight b5 is a candidate
move any other candidate moves coming to
mind
what other checks are in the position
let's just throw some out here
yeah Rick i-4 is a reasonable idea
trying to take away some of these
defenders around the king any any other
ideas so we have 95 RK 4 do it
yeah so of course the night takes is one
of the moves you have to calculate as
well as Rick takes so let's take a look
at night b5 first and see okay so Rick
takes b5 is the only move and now is
there any follow-up for for white here
that you guys can see cuz I'm not sure I
do actually see it once again you can't
really just take take material here
because well black is threatening
checkmate as always so so I don't think
95 quite works but let's take a look at
a true k4 and how did you want to
recapture this rook
yeah so that the night makes makes a lot
of sense I'm actually going to put rook
takes on the board first and this is
actually kind of a puzzle within a
puzzle here well I guess I guess it
always is but checkmate in two from this
position no wait sorry checkmate and uh
yeah let's just start with the knight
days it's checkmate in a few the idea is
very very similar in both lines but but
we'll do we'll do Knight takes first and
now you have checkmate in just a few
moves actually so how can we how can we
achieve such a thing
hello to everyone in the YouTube chat
he's a pretty tough puzzle but
see what you guys can come up with here
yeah this is always a natural move but I
don't know if it accomplishes enough
here we could we could always just take
yeah
yeah
okay YouTube chat has an idea they want
to try Queen takes a four and so once
again there's two branches there's Rick
takes and King takes let's start with
King takes because this is the the
simpler one how does white checkmate
here at rook over
Queen a6 and this is actually checkmate
so okay that leaves rook takes and then
can we find a checkmate from rook takes
a for someone in YouTube has it I'll
give you a moment though DM has it in
the YouTube chat
okay I'll give you the next move Bishop
d6 check is important if your key for
your okay it is still checkmate and a
Forex c5 rook b3 is simply checkmate
so yeah Queen takes d6 is next and now
checkmate and - can you find it with
your two remaining pieces
checkmate and - oh well not quiet right
if we count the material oh and this is
actually check but even if you could
take black would still be totally with
totally winning with the number of
pieces so not an IP five
checkmate in two yes so Ben's Simon has
it rook p3 check nowhere for the King to
go rook takes his force and then of
course the checkmate night c2 as we said
and we see one piece left for white
checkmating the black king due to the
unfortunate placement of the rooks so
this was just a fun little puzzle I
wanted to have see you guys get warmed
up here so in this main line white gives
away all those pieces in order to
achieve this this structure and distract
this Queen and then it's it's simply
checkmate so well done to everybody who
found that in the YouTube chat as well
very very quickly it's a very similar
line if rook takes this plate first of
course with Knight takes we had to play
Queen takes before we did anything else
but now what should we do instead
it's a very similar idea
so Queen b3 doesn't quite work you have
to get the move order right because we
still have this queen defending the c2
squared so we have to do something
something about this Queen first yeah
it's the same idea
so Bishop check and if Queen takes Queen
b3 in night c2 you can throw in a rook
to c5 but we'll simply take it and if
you play rook b4 let's see if I can
remember the solution to my own puzzle
here it looks like Knight b5 is simply
matin for real this time thanks to the
pin on on the rook and so that's just
just a quick puzzle that that I wanted
you guys to warm up with hopefully that
got you guys thinking let's move on to a
few games here so this first one like I
said these are all from the moscow world
rapid championship that just took place
at the end of december and this one was
between magnus carlsen and alexander
siminoff and magnus had the white pieces
and so let's see how they both players
treated this opening magnus played efore
shimon i played the caro-kann and we see
d4 d5 magnus goes for the exchange
Bishop d3 knight c6 c3 and Queen c7 from
Shimon off this is a little bit of an
older line these days you know most of
the time simply Knight f6 is played and
there are ideas of bringing this Bishop
out to actually this kind of
weird-looking East six square as well as
being ket owing this Bishop with g6 and
Bishop g7 but Shimon off chose Queen c7
Magnus plays h3 and this is kind of not
the most natural way of playing with
white right you've moved a few pawns but
does anybody know what the idea is
between this h3 move and and developing
the pieces in this kind of strange order
what can Magnus be be thinking with
these moves
he's actually playing to prevent
something from from black
one way to look at it is where would you
like to develop your pieces if you're
black and let's say white had just
developed normally where would you like
to develop your pieces with black yeah
exactly right you would like to bring
this Bishop out to g4 this is the main
point and so by playing h3 first Magnus
is taking away both of the natural
developing squares away from this bishop
and so this is actually the main idea of
whites opening here he wants to prove an
advantage because he's going to say that
this bishop can't be developed to a good
square and the bishops gonna be bad and
that's that's how I'm gonna gain an
advantage and so like I said
historically this problem is sometimes
been solved by playing g6
and Bishop g7 and actually eventually
Bishop f5 sometimes gets played here
going for this type of fun structure or
allowing this type of pawn structure if
white so desires and this is a pretty
interesting way of playing it's kind of
combative there's imbalances and so this
is the main way that black usually plays
against this Bishop d3 and h3 set up is
by playing this g6 and Bishop f5 line
but it's at the same time
Alex Gemini was playing Magnus Carlsen
and perhaps he was afraid of going for
such an interesting line and so instead
he went back to the old way of doing
things which is simply developing the
pieces and accepting that this Bishop is
going to be locked behind the pawns and
playing a six and this is kind of the
point I want to make about the fear in
chests here for this game you can't
really change your openings to this
degree because you're afraid of your
opponent maybe you can choose not to
play the caro-kann if you're worried
about this line and play some some other
opening but what you can't do is go in
for for the caro-kann and then not play
you know the best lines at this top
level because you're afraid of your
opponent you have to once you commit to
the opening you can't play subpar lines
just because you think your opponent's
going to know it better than you or be
able to navigate it
than you once you start making
concessions like that you've already
admitted a lot in the game and just as a
very psychology heavy game you know once
you start admitting things like well I
can't play this line because they'll
know what better than me next thing you
know you stop trusting your calculation
because you think well my opponent's
better than me he'll have calculated
further than me so I can't go for this
line that I've calculated and it kind of
spirals so it's really important in your
games when you're playing a higher rated
player to play what you're comfortable
with play what you know and and not
really change it too much because you're
afraid of your opponent because you
think they'll you know understand it
better than you so that's the point I'm
making really early on even for move
seven which is it's kind of a nuance
thing to see blacks choosing this line
over another line but it really is
relevant at this level choosing choosing
a subpar line so castles Bishop d6 rook
e1 b6 and black is saying I'll develop
the bishop out this way but really the
fact is this bishop isn't isn't doing
much on b7 either we see Knight bTW -
Bishop b7 simply Queen e2 for Magnus
keeps an eye both on the a6 square as
well as the e4 square as well as the e5
square of course you know Bishop a6
would possibly be an eventual idea to
trade off the bishops doesn't really
make so much sense here but the pressure
along the e file is quite relevant
castles 95 rook a e8 and we actually see
Bishop b1 from Magnus so I'm sure this
is an idea some of you have seen before
in your games
dropping this Bishop back to b1 is is
actually a pretty significant tell what
is what is Magnus aiming for here with
Bishop b1 should immediately be able to
guess
which diagonal
[Music]
yeah b12 h7 so how is he well how does
Bishop be one yeah this is this is a
very relevant thing this Bishop is
trapped behind blacks pawns and so
Magnus is gonna make use of this long
open diagonal but what is Bishop b1
saying specifically what's gonna happen
on this diagonal what is magnets gonna
do
he's clearing the d3 square for another
one of his pieces
how can you add more pressure to the
diagonal exactly right he wants to play
queen d3 and this is a very very common
way to put pressure on the Kings side
and if black isn't careful black will
get immediately checkmated of course
we've all seen that combo before with
the Queen being supported by the bishop
checkmating the king and if black is
careful he's still gonna have to make
some concessions on the Kings side in
order to survive such an attack so
that's what Magnus is saying he wants to
do with with Bishop e1 in response
Shimon off played 97 trying to trade off
this the strong knight on e5
Magnus simply responds with Knight DF 3
supporting this Knight once again from
from the trade and now Shimon off plays
f6 Magnus responds with Queen d3 once
again the point being it's a little
uncomfortable to defend this h7 Square
especially with this bishop trapped
behind the pawns and so Shimon AAB has
to make a concession he plays f5 and
this is already pretty pretty terrible
for black I'm willing to say so what's
what's the big problem in blacks
position here there's a few
uh yeah you're worried about more more
kingside stuff maybe okay that's fair
enough
there's some very definite weaknesses in
blacks position that he's gonna have to
worry about one might be the Kings side
but there's one more in particular that
that's really kind of glaring
so that's that's another good point
actually these pieces are a little bit
disjointed right now these four pieces
all have the common goal of removing
this knight on e5 but like I said this
Bishop isn't really contributing and
these rooks as well are a little unclear
on what their their role is in this
position so it's another problem the big
weakness that I'm talking about though
is actually this pawn on e6 by forcing
black to push this pawn up to f5 no more
pawns can defend this e 6 1 and if white
manages to maintain control over the e5
square this is gonna be a permanent
weakness for black it's going to be
really really tough for shim not to
defend so already 15 moves into the game
black is significantly worse right and
it makes you think you know maybe black
would have would have also lost this
game had he gone for this more active
lion I'm gonna say the best line for
black but you know maybe you also would
have lost in that that game but this one
is kind of giving up without a fight
right you've let Magnus do what he wants
Magnus now has a weakness and the rest
of the game you're gonna be on the back
foot defending against the weaknesses
trying to record innate your pieces and
that's just not a fun way to play chess
so the fear in this game kind of led to
shim nobs demise but let's see some more
moves currently there still is a threat
to this night let's see there's three
defenders and four attackers so you
can't quite just ignore it
so Bishop f4 defends once again Knight
f6 is shriman off choice perhaps trying
to make use of this Square and then
after Bishop h2 dropping the bishop back
avoiding any any kind of g5s any kind of
Knight h5 s we see Knight d8 get played
trying to unveil this Bishop perhaps
reroute this night and then Magnus plays
a move that's really really common for
these types of structures actually kind
of
for both sides this this is kind of an
idea but whenever you see puns like this
there's a very very common way to try
and create more weaknesses to create a
weakness on this side of the board
so how can we try and weaken this this
pawn structure a little bit okay
yet so that that's one idea right is you
know imagining if this pawn came to a6
to kick this queen away from v5 then
maybe these pawns would both be a little
bit looser but of course one black
doesn't have to kick this Queen away in
that manner there's there's a number of
things but I could do here and - this
isn't actually such a weak pawn
structure it's very fluid meaning if one
pawn is attacks you can push it forward
to defend it or you can actually push
the other pawn forward and to defend
both pawns similarly depending on what's
what's correct so we want something else
to kind of force blacks hands with with
force blacks hand with these two pawns
and that's normally done the upon storm
of white zone and so very quickly I'm
gonna now launch up around but that move
is a four as Aziz in the the YouTube
chat has found and so now if black does
nothing about it we're simply gonna play
a five and next we're gonna play a takes
B six and if obviously if Queen takes
now this pawn is weak and if pawn takes
now this B six pawn is also without
without a defender and so we've found
activity on this side of the board we
have a weakness over here to target a
weakness over here to target with our
pieces and with two weaknesses it'll be
a lot easier to win so a four is always
an idea to keep in mind you can do it in
structures like this you can actually do
it in structures where let's say these
three pawns are all off the board it
still makes sense to use this a pawn to
shake loose the a7 b6 kind of dynamic
it's a very common very common plan so a
for black did not want to allow a5 so he
played it himself and now Magnus just
starts playing very very simply he has
the type of position that that Magnus
really is as great at although he's
great at many types of positions but
what I'm talking about is black has
created weaknesses White has not really
created weaknesses and Magnus can now
just take his time win the game
there's no rush there's no complications
to figure out he just has to attack
these weaknesses and eventually black
will crumble and that's what happened
this game I saw Queenie to tonight does
come to e4 and the bishop comes out to
d3 once again there's really no more
attack on this diagonal
thanks to this this push that Black has
done and but the purpose has been served
the weaknesses have been created so now
Magnus is simply shiftings pieces back
we see f4 and now c4 and so black trying
to expand on this side of the board has
loosened up his control of the e4 square
and Magnus seizes this pawn to kind of
show that we see ricky 7 this turret
comes to c1 and now really the dis
coordination of the black pieces is
showing and Magnus simply wants to open
up the position to make use of that C
Queen B 8c takes d5 he takes d5 so
Magnus's fix this weakness in order to
open up the position this should be 5
and forces pretty much Bishop takes
otherwise 97 is is kind of coming so
Bishop takes clears the d6 squared for
the Queen now we do see f3 from Magnus
of course the difference between these
two knights is that this F pawn has
already been pushed and this F pawn can
still shake loose this night the night
comes to g3 captures captures Queen e3
and this is just a tough position for
black here after Knight c6 you can't
really capture this to get rid of your
bishop because rip takes attacks many
many many pieces all at the same time so
Rickie 8 instead and now after Queen e5
takes takes King h8 there was simply too
much too much activity for white and so
a tactic kind of appears with Knight
takes a5 after takes C takes takes and
after rook e1 Bishop c8 black for the
moment has two pieces for for the rook
as well as a pawn but White's Turks are
so active that the game quickly kind of
falls
part rekka fate takes and now with
connected passed pawns on the queenside
this is a very very easy win for for
white you see the the last few moves get
played
Magnus just pushes this pawn and there's
nothing to be done here Magnus is gonna
make a queen and win the game
so any questions about how it all kind
of fell apart for black there it was
really all in the opening on an Magnus
did some Magnus things and transferred
the the pawn weakness and to an
advantage in activity along the C file
and use that to kind of win the game but
really blacks mistakes came through in
the opening that's where he lost this
game but any any other questions about
it okay wonderful
so main points don't change
your opening play because you're afraid
of your opponent you want to play what's
best for you what you're comfortable
with what you know and switching that up
going back to an old line in the hopes
that maybe Magnus won't remember as much
about it is never gonna be a good plan
you want to play what you know you want
to play what's best and then just a
brief idea here making use of this open
diagonal because black has committed
this bishop to up to a worse diagonal is
how Magnus kind of showed the faults in
blacks opening play and then lastly this
a4 idea is very common to break up this
the structure as always the principle of
two weaknesses right you have a weakness
here you wanna make a weakness on the
Queen side those are the main points I
wanted to hit now I want to take a look
at a very very fun game between Peter
Svidler
and Ali Riza fruga of course Peters
fiddler is one of the all-time greats in
the Greenfeld defense perhaps the
greatest Greenfeld player to ever play
the opening Peter stood there knows
knows his stuff in the green field if
there's one thing you can say about
Peter stood there that he's a great
green felt player so with that in mind
with the black pieces one thing you
might try to avoid is is playing the
green felt because Peter Svidler knows
his stuff he knows the lines and if you
play it against him you better you
better know what you're up
so we didn't get there directly
but after g3 and Bishop g7 Bishop g2
castles d4 Peters fiddler has adopted
for a kind of a Catalan type structure
with you know developing and the Queen
slide like this but after d5 black runs
in to the green felt course mcgriffin
felt being denoted by playing this d5
and allowing white this option to take
with the pawn and black will have to
recapture with the night and so the idea
of this opening is that even though you
waste some time capturing this problem
with the night and getting kicked away
with another pawn what you do end up
achieving is forcing well not really
forcing but allowing me to kind of go
over extend into the center and with
this over extension you want to attack
the center and try to prove that it's
more of a weakness than an asset so this
is my next point about fear and chess it
can be useful right so Alireza goes into
the green felled fearlessly against
Peter Svidler one of the greatest screen
role players of all time and this might
be the case where it might be wiser in
fact to choose a different opening line
I'm not saying play the Greenfeld but
play you know a simpler version of the
green field because that's not what's
going to work we saw that in the
previous game already work out for
Magnus and not work out for Shimon oov
but at the same time you could avoid
playing the green felt against Peters
Fiddler's and the rest of this game I
just wanted to go over because it's it's
kind of a it's a really good example of
what makes Peters feather so great and
why perhaps you shouldn't play the green
field against him so far this is all
kind of charted waters these moves have
been played before I call this still
theory we see queenie one hits this
knight on a five the knight comes to see
for white develops this Knight to c3
black challenges the center with c6 of
course that's the idea of his opening
you want to challenge the the
overextended center
b3 is actually White's choice and if you
take a look this night is a little bit
stuck actually you can come to e5 I
suppose but let's see
so black instead of moving this night
around even more is what I'm trying to
say he goes for a sacrifice with with
pawn takes d5
the idea being after white captures the
knight as white does black gets to
totally rip open the center in exchange
as well as he has some very nasty
pressure along this diagonal which he's
going to hope to to use to reclaim some
material first off for white this Knight
is attacked so he moves it out of the
way black continues with f5 trying to
keep this stronghold in the center in
exchange for this this pressure on the
diagonal and that's that's his
compensation for the full piece we saw
at Bishop e3 and now Queen d3 from Ali
Riza is his choice to regain material
and here a Peter does a very very nice
nice thing for for white and what he
does is give some of the material back
this is a very very common idea in
high-level games when one player plays a
sacrifice he wants to get a ton of
compensation a ton of activity for it
and very often the best thing to do with
the player with more material is to give
some of it back to alleviate some of
this pressure some of this compensation
and once you give it back you'll still
be up a slight edge in material and you
can use that that you know that less
extreme material imbalance to to your
advantage to take away some of that
activity and so that's what Peter does
one option for white here would be to
play a move like rook c1 trying to hold
on to everything but this I don't think
is is a very good idea here I'm not sure
what what the direct refutation is off
the top of my head but by wasting more
time defending things like this Knight
you allow black to still have this this
very nasty [ __ ]
and perhaps black can just continue
simply with something like Knight takes
e4 taking more puns away from the white
camp and instead of that instead of
allowing black all this activity what
Peter does is plays Knight d5 offering
up the exchange in return he's going to
trade off some of these active pieces
and that is exactly what happens Knight
takes d5 C takes d5 Queen takes d5 and
once again this Bishop is so active that
Peter chooses not to care in the
slightest he doesn't move the rook out
of the way giving another pawn instead
simply Queen before allowing Bishop
takes a1 and your take same one and so
now that the smoke is has kind of
finally cleared black finishes
development with Bishop u6 and this is
kind of the position we have reached and
already a lot of things have been
decided here it's a very very imbalanced
position but it's one I'm sure Peter
kind of understands better than his
opponent which is which is the problem
so let's kind of take stock of what
happened here what is our current
material count this is a difficult
question compared to most material
counts questions because it's kind of
wildly imbalanced but let's just take
stock we have one two three four five
six seven ponds for black merely four
pawns for white but in return we see one
roof or each side one queen for each
side one Bishop for each side
White has two pieces for the rook and so
it is White's task to prove that this
imbalance of two pieces for the rook is
in fact worth the full three pawns and
generally it shouldn't be right we say
two pieces is worth about a rook and
upon sometimes a rook into pawns but
three pawns is is pretty extreme so
let's try and find you know where is
Peters activity coming from where is
this compensation for now being down in
material what do you guys think where is
the compensation yet one thing is this
pawn on e7 can in fact be captured so
you know well we could take it
immediately now perhaps this isn't what
what Peter had had in mind
I think Bishop f7 would have to be
played and now actually this Queen you
know it's fine on e7 but it's it could
be doing more but the point stands eise
evan is weak and can kind of be captured
at many many moments
so there's one thing in particular that
that black has done here and that is
he's pushed a lot of these pawns forward
right and what that has left is some
open space around this King and
specifically these diagonals are very
very very much open so what happens when
you have open diagonals and you're
facing the bishop pair you run into
trouble right so this is the big
compensation that Peter has for for this
extra one or two pawns is that these
diagonals are going to be great great
homes for for whites bishops and already
he goes to to make use of it right he's
threatening already a tactic to to win
material he wants to bring these bishops
on to these open diagonals and harass
the the black king in exchange Alireza
plays rook a c8 with the idea of
covering the square trying to prevent
the bishops room from arriving there now
Peter takes the time to take off the
last defender of this diagonal with
Knight takes c6 and also allowing Queen
takes b7 so Peter regains one of the one
of the pawns that he's down he still has
these monster bishops in these wide-open
diagonals actually aiming at both sides
of the board and this is actually just
far too much for for black to handle
this is I would I would be willing to
say this is close to winning winning for
white
despite material White has far more
active chances for his pieces so we see
Queen f6 hitting the ricchan a one rook
d1 g5 is played rook d7 and even the the
white major pieces are doing better than
black here cking f7 Queen d5 check Queen
D 5 and now Bishop takes g5 the bishop
was of course covering many many squares
and now with material coming back into
White's favor the piece activity really
shows and the game is quickly decided
just just a quick note of warning never
go in for any endgame where you have a
rook against two bishops and in just the
clear endgame the bishops are so much
more powerful than the rook they cover
so many more squares that it's it's
almost always going to be winning for
the side with the bishops and that holds
true here we see g4 and now white has
created a passed pawn and that is more
than enough to win the game we see him
advance this pawn and now the bishop
will come and escort this pawn all the
way down the board and that is how
firoozeh who had a phenomenal tournament
a phenomenal showing in the world rapid
actually dropped a game here to Peter's
fit there so where did black actually go
wrong it is an interesting question and
I think it's one that can be determined
by it by the opening Peter chose this
specific line which very clearly is
wildly imbalanced and gives white a lot
of chances gives both sides a lot of
chances but because you know he's the
best green felt player in the world
he understood the position better and
once you know the game kind of deviated
from totally known territory with this
Bishop III move a novelty from Svidler
perhaps perhaps Persia wasn't entirely
prepared to to meet the complications
that that the position was asking for
fact here it's it's already a bit better
for white and after Queen d3
it's simply much much better this ninety
five idea I think was discovered over
the board and it's already plus two for
white after we see some some accurate
moves this is simply simply much better
for white and that's the risk you run
when you go into an opening that you
know your opponent is kind of a
specialist in so this is kind of the
line that I wanted to walk with this
lecture on the one hands you can't play
afraid you can't play moves that you
know to not be you know perhaps the best
because you're afraid of what your
opponent knows but at the same time you
absolutely don't want to play the
Enfield against the world's greatest
Greenfeld player and these are very
extreme examples right this is chess at
the top level but you can apply it to
your own games as well say you know you
you've you know who you're gonna play
you know your opponent you've known him
for years and whenever you play the the
Slav you always get destroyed you know
he knows this line much much better than
you so going in does that mean you
should play a worse version of this love
to avoid that the line that you know
that he's really good at no but what
that does mean is perhaps you should
look at some other opening choices you
don't have to play this love you can
play some other opening that perhaps you
both have less experience in and just
you know get a chess game but that's
really the goal here you just want to
get a chess game and Shimon oov didn't
really get a chess game because he
played a passive line and immediately
had weaknesses to deal with and
meanwhile firoozeh didn't really get a
chess game because he got outplayed in
the opening he didn't know the opening
well enough he went to the other side of
the pendulum he went totally complicated
wild wild opening but when you do that
against someone who's a specialist then
you run the risk of just getting
destroyed which is what happened so
those were the two main main opening
lines that I wanted to show this is how
fear can kind of impact your game you
can play to passively or if you're
totally unafraid you can go in for
complications against some that you
shouldn't alright any questions about
this game it's kind of a wild one but I
think that the the the point I made was
was not not too crazy right it's very
clear that Peter Svidler understood this
opening better than fruga and because of
that that's why freesia lost but okay
any questions
all right no well let's move on to game
number three for the night
we have Magnus Carlsen against Liam Lee
the Vietnamese player who actually
formerly has won I believe the world
rapid championship and so it's
interesting to see him here back again
competing with the world's best in this
case in Magnus Carlsen so let's see how
this game transpired we see d4 d5 c4d
takes e4 and Magnus chooses efore a very
interesting line in the Queens gambit
accepted for those theoreticians out
there usually lately Knight f3 has been
a very very common way to play with the
white pieces guarding against any e5
breaks before you you go about your
business reclaiming this pawn in this
case though Magnus simply plays d4 and
now after Knight of 6 e 595 and what
Magnus is doing here is similar to what
we've seen kind of in the Greenfeld
it's the modern way to approach the
center black gives white a big center in
the hopes of being able to to tear it
down shortly in this case though we see
we should take c4 Knight b6 Bishop b3
this Bishop comes out to f5 and now
after Knight f3 + e 693 knight c6 Bishop
e3 Bishop e7 we see kind of a strange
line from black here what black has done
is allowed white to keep the center for
for quite some time and what that means
it's not bad yet for for black for black
but black does have to be kind of on his
toes he has to do something about this
Center because generally if you just let
the center sit for a long long time and
you let white develop his pieces around
it eventually it will be worse for black
so what you need to do is find some way
to tear it down and that happens in a
few different ways in this opening but
the main thing that is generally done as
black plays Queen d7 and castles Queen
side
so of course the center guards this f6
square meaning there's some problems on
the kingside for black so black castles
Queen side and at the same time adds
much more pressure to this d4 square and
this is generally the prescribed way of
handling this opening these days instead
though we see Bishop e7 which is by no
means a bad move but after white castles
black also castles King side and perhaps
this is this is Liam Lee being a little
bit flustered kind of forgetting
forgetting the the main ideas of this is
opening you know by castling kingside
he's he's already making some
concessions here he's giving Magnus
something to play for and this is kind
of a kind of a problem and I mean I'm no
armchair psychologist but you know
perhaps and some of this comes from from
being afraid of Magnus you know we see
players all the time not going for the
main lines not going for the main stuff
against Magnus and I think that that
stems from the sphere that Magnus knows
what he's doing in all these main lines
but by playing something a little bit
offbeat that doesn't always increase
your chances and in fact this is one of
those cases so we see a 395 hitting this
bishop forcing white to relocate he
chooses the c2 Square and now this next
move was was really really where black
black started to go very very wrong
so Bishop c2 what's what's a natural way
to respond to this
what's the natural way to respond to
Bishop e2 and the tension between these
bishops you have a couple options I
think
yeah so you can take the bishop or you
can move the bishop out of the way
either to g4 or even g6
I'm not so sure I like Bishop g4 because
once again when you vacate this diagonal
you run into some potential problems in
this case obviously this bishop could
just come back here but you do have to
be on the lookout for problems on age 7
but I very much like taking the bishop
and even Bishop g6 I think is a playable
move here what you don't want to do is
what happened in the game
what black plate is Queen d7 and this
allows white to trade the bishops on
very very favorable terms white gets to
play pawn to Bishop takes Bishop forcing
pawn takes Bishop and now these pawns
are much more dangerous than they used
to be the main idea of of this opening
for black is that these pawns well very
far advanced while controlling some key
squares they aren't you know fluid it's
tough to get them rolling right and we
see in this position the only way to
kind of advance this central structure
is through this d5 square and right now
white simply doesn't have enough
material aimed at d5 in order to achieve
that meaning black has this d5 square
well under control
and so then eventually you might see a
move like rook c8 and a move like c5
with the idea that this pawn is going to
be the weakness this is how black
generally treats the structure and so if
you're going to allow this change in
structure with takes and takes you
really need to control this d5 square
and perhaps Liam Lee thought he was
controlling the d5 square but in this
case he's simply not let's see what
could have been like let's say a white
wasted at a tempo somehow with King h1
what should black play here almost
immediately just to be sure that d5
isn't going to get played
yeah you can play c6 that's one of your
choices even simply Knight d5 is another
choice for black but at all costs you
have to stop d5 and so of course white
doesn't want to waste a tempo here white
simply plays d5 and now this position is
is pretty hopeless for black hopeless
might be extreme but it's very very good
for white of course now White has the
option to respond to any threats to his
pawns by advancing even further and even
some ideas of creating more tension you
know these ponds are our fluid and
that's what you want to avoid when
giving your opponent a big center you
want to avoid those pawns getting
rolling down the board so after d5
Magnus really is simply winning already
but let's see what happened here
Knight AC 4 was Liam Lee's choice
hitting this bishop Magnus actually
chooses to trade off the Knights on B 6
and now Magnus simply plays rook b3 and
let me ask you what what Magnus's next
two moves are gonna be assuming black
doesn't make any threats it's very very
simple chess and this is kind of the
problem for black here white doesn't do
anything special
he simply plays the most natural moves
and they're very very good for him
so let's say you know black like you
know make some some slight improving
move what are what are whites next to
moves this isn't like a huge puzzle or
anything it's it's just very natural
play
yeah you just bring the rucks to the
center that's that's all you have to do
and that's exactly what happened Rick d8
rook d1 Rick yep
rook e1 and now all of whites pieces are
perfectly placed supporting the strong
Center and meanwhile blacks pieces you
might say our place to attack the center
but the fact is you don't have enough
support and this Bishop is quite quite
awkward for black and so the game
continued with g6
just kind of a strengthening move for
black and now white simply sits on the
center which is horribly cramping these
black minor pieces as well as even the
black major pieces and he plays h4 just
taking his time
King g7 h5 probing for weaknesses after
Bishop c5 Queen c2 a5 is played for
black black is really kind of trying to
improve his pieces but it's very very
difficult to improve around such such a
strong center and that's kind of the
theme of the game
Queen c1 was played Queen e7 and now
after Queen ax 497 like I said trying to
find ways to improve the pieces but this
Knight has no forward forward advancing
moves due to the strength of the white
center so 97 and now let's let's see I
guess this is this is a moment when when
Magnus really kind of breaks through so
I'll ask you guys to find Magnus's next
move it's justified via tactical means
but it's a way to open up the position
now that we've placed our pieces on
really good squares and even created
some threats on this side of the board
as well
so I'll give you a hint before I
actually set you loose on this one so a
huge advantage to the center is it gives
you the the opportunity to swing your
pieces to either side of the board very
very quickly right you can see this
knight can easily jump to the Queen side
this Queen has full rein over the fourth
rank to go back and forth so something
that's useful to do when you have a big
Center is to open things up on both
sides of the board so we already have
some threats on the Kings side if if
black isn't careful involving something
like h6 and using this diagonal but now
we want to make some threats on on the
Queen side so how can we open the Queen
side
yeah b4 but can you can you play before
and does it work
so what happens in this line so not
saying it's wrong I'm just saying you
have to solve this problem yeah that's
exactly right there's a nice what we
call an interference tactic of pawn to
d6 blocking the Queen's support of the
bishop of course you don't have time to
save the bishop or take this Knight
because the Queen is hanging and if you
want to take this pawn what's white play
now oh so I guess you can't actually
take it back I was originally thinking
simply Queen takes bishop but I think
this move is actually much more powerful
you can't recapture because of Queen
takes and you can't you know just move
the screen out of the way because of
Queen takes bishop and so d6 would be
the tactic justifying this I do want to
mention though some people in the
YouTube chat were suggesting east six
here so what do you guys think about
this this East six move
is this a good one or a bad one it
certainly is opening things up which is
kind of how I presented the problem
but is this a good idea for for white or
not in this case
yeah it opens up this diagonal as well
as this diagonal right and in addition
to that it's trying to open up this EE
file but is east six that the type of
move well okay it's it's a very leading
question so I'll just I'll just tell you
II 6 is not the type of move you can
play lightly east six is actually giving
up quite a bit so from this position
these strong central pawns are very much
cramping the black pieces and what I
mean when I say that is they control all
of these 6th ranked squares that would
be great to put blacks pieces on to we
can't put these pieces here because
these pawns are placed the way they are
and after a move like e6000 seen has
been greatly improved because the
addition of these two squares for his
pieces is very very nice
for black you have advanced your Center
further creating some more threats but
you've allowed black to get his pieces
back into the game and yeah I will say
so of course here rook takes I think
would just be winning because of this
problem for for black but black and
throw in Bishop d6 first and then this
one is much much less clear because once
again black has found Pete squares first
pieces so II 6 these types of moves can
sometimes just be winning the game by it
by forcing things open but if they
aren't immediately like winning then you
really don't want to play them because
it gives up a lot of your control in the
center so that's why b4 was played here
opening things up on the Queen side we
see pawn takes pawn takes this Bishop
comes back once again we saw this tactic
with d6 against Bishop b4 so this should
be 6 instead
and now this piece has been even further
sidelined from defending against the
central central threats and let's see
how Magnus finished it off h6 King g8
now there's always threats on this
diagonal and d6 was his final choice to
really end the game here this was the
way that Magnus chose to to finally
release the tension in the center and
open things up so why is d6 a better
move than a 6
for example why not why not a six here
from from white what was the reason I
said that this move was not really what
what white should be doing yeah it goes
up the d6 and the f6 squares and these
scores are very very useful for the
black pieces where as d6 gives up which
squares yeah
c6 and e6 and so d6 is a good move
because of Magnussen's follow up which
doesn't allow the black pieces to
actually use these squares effectively
black plays Queen f8 if black were to
actually capture this piece I think
there's some problems involving Knight
d5 as well as as simply recapturing but
okay so Queen f8 instead removing the
Queen from the immediate threats of
Knight d5 and now Magnus continues with
a 6 which is a very very mean move
completely ripping open the entire
center now that white has enough threats
to to just be winning so F takes c6 and
now he takes c7 and black gets this e6
pawn white gets the c7 pawn and this is
just tactically losing the rook has to
move and now we can take this free night
and the game very quickly reaches a
conclusion white already up a piece has
yet another tactic to win the game and
that's how it all actually collapsed
freely Emily so this game what went
wrong was black made a very very very
strange decision to allow Wyatt to
capture this Bishop on f5 and the only
circumstance you would ever want to do
this is if you have total control over
the d5 square already such such that you
don't mind giving up this this defender
in this case he didn't have that and
Magnus kind of just steamrolled him and
so once again and the topic for tonight
was kind of fear in chess as well as
just taking a look at these these games
from the rap and World Championship
and so in the first two games in the
first game in particular Shimon off
played a passive line with black because
he was afraid of Magnus and the second
game Perugia fearless leap laid the
Greenfeld against Peter Svidler kind of
swinging the other way a little bit too
a little bit too far when in fact
sometimes you need to respect your
opponent a little bit more and not play
a worse opening line but play one that
you know he's less familiar with and
then in this game it's tough to
attribute this this to fear but Liam Lee
played such a weird way against Magnus
that you get the feeling there was
something psychological going on here
against a low level level Grandmaster I
don't think Liam Lee would have allowed
Bishop takes f5 it's a very very strange
move to allow it's a very kind of basic
mistake to make and perhaps that had
something to do with with him sitting
across from the world champion so any
questions on the lecture overall tonight
no okay well thank you all very very
much for joining me this has been the
first edition of Road to 2000 and in
quite a while so well I'm happy to be
back doing more of these lectures in the
new year here hopefully I will see you
all next week thanks very much
you
[Music]